i know you guys are starving for
hogwarts legacy news trust me me too
today i'm going to tell you when and
where i think we'll get a new update
also if you don't follow the official
social accounts for hogwarts legacy i'll
catch you up on
all of their social media posts so far
including some recent activity
people of the internet retrorec contour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell we post videos
every week here on youtube and also
stream over on twitch
for all the latest hogwarts legacy news
be sure you subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss any of the new
updates rumors or theories about the
game so it has been two and a half
months since hogwarts legacy was
officially unveiled back at the
playstation showcase event in september
and it's actually been years if you
count the unofficial leaks we've gotten
for this game before it was ever made
official now we've talked at length
about the trailer here on this channel
already we've also touched on the
official faq on the hogwarts legacy
website
as well as a playstation blog post with
adrian ropp of
avalanche software if you've missed any
of those be sure to check out my full
hogwarts legacy playlist
in terms of official news the only thing
we haven't touched on so far here on the
channel
are the social media accounts so that's
what we're going to do
today as well as a little speculation on
when and where
i think we'll get further news for
hogwarts legacy now the official social
media accounts for the game actually
went live
on september 16th so that same day that
they revealed it
with the trailer at the playstation
showcase that is when these accounts
went live
now they have accounts set up for
twitter facebook instagram and they also
have a discord as well from what i can
tell the content is pretty much the same
across
all of those social platforms i'm going
to be focused on twitter today since
that's just what i use most of the time
but they have a total of 14
tweets that's it 14 in two and a half
months
so let's just go through those tweets
one by one here and see if we can spot
anything that we've missed so far okay
so the pinned tweet here at the top is
actually from september 16th this was
their very first tweet and it is just
the trailer you can see here 85 000
likes so i'm going to scroll all the way
to the bottom
so we already saw the pinned tweet that
was their very first tweet
this was their second tweet start your
hogwarts legacy by following all of our
official
channels so this is something they
talked about in the trailer the fact
that in this game we're going to be
leaving our legacy on the wizarding
world we know choice is going to be a
big part of that
going up to the next one here it gets
even more in depth welcome
to aguero's legacy this was also on
september 16th and it has a really nice
image here this is the official
wallpaper that you can get by signing up
for their newsletter or you can just go
online and search for it if you want to
find it but in all honesty it is a
really nice wallpaper we've actually
broken it down and there's all sorts of
little details you can find in here
so so far not much to go on uh but this
one right here they actually respond to
a question i really hope that hogwarts
legacy isn't exclusive to the ps5
i want to play on pc man so this can
kind of happen sometimes when
playstation or xbox reveal games
at their event so they didn't
specifically say this is ps5 exclusive
it just happened to be unveiled at
the sony event so they actually respond
because they want this to be known right
away for those curious hogwarts legacy
will be available for ps5
ps4 ps4 pro the xbox one family of
devices including xbox series x
and xbox one x and pc
now they don't specifically call out
xbox series s but it will certainly be
available on that one as well so this is
pretty much coming to
every major platform with the exception
of the nintendo switch which is kind of
disappointing because i know there's a
lot of switch fans out there
but hopefully with it being available in
so many other places everybody who wants
to be able to get a copy and play this
will be able to do so
all right now september 17th so the next
day things start to get
a little bit juicy here your hogwarts
legacy is defined by the choices you
make
now so we know this game is an open
world action rpg they've talked about
that
basically everywhere that they've
communicated anything about this game
that has been mentioned and they also
keep coming back to this idea of choice
our choices are going to matter now
they're talking about this so much
to me it's going to be very important
that those choices have
impact i talked about that in the last
video when we discussed some of my
biggest concerns for the game
anytime when you have player choice
involved you really have to make sure
that those choices have meaning and they
have
weight and the game needs to feel
different when we're a dark wizard
versus a light wizard and because
they're hyping this up so much i am
hopeful that they'll be able to do that
all right
going up to the next one here september
21st so a few days later the sorting hat
ceremony awaits you in the great hall
there's been a lot of speculation a lot
of fans want to know
how will we be sorted will there be some
sort of quiz will you just get to choose
will it actually link to
pottermore i know some people were
hopeful of that at the end of the day i
think it's just going to be as simple as
we
choose our house maybe they'll have a
little quiz in the game and then you can
change it if you want to but it actually
says directly in the faq that you will
be able to choose
your house at the start of the game so i
think this sorting ceremony will be one
of the first things we do
september 22nd they respond to another
fan question who says show
us gameplay i guess not really a
question more of a statement or a demand
show us gameplay
and then they respond by saying who said
we haven't shown it
already now if you guys are as hyped as
i am we've seen that trailer
so many times now that there are various
moments where you can pick out
that look to be more gameplay and not
necessarily a cut scene
a couple of that i can think of right
off the bat uh the hippogriff flying
scene we're gonna see that here in a
second but that one
to me looks like it's game play also
there's a moment when you see a student
walking into a common room i think
that's game play and i actually think
the scene when the dragon is kind of
right in front of the player and we see
the player
diving off to the left i think that is
his gameplay as well
there are probably various other moments
that you can find in the trailer if you
spot any let me know down in the
comments but i
i definitely think we have seen gameplay
they pretty much confirm in here the
question is just how much
september 23rd the next day another
juicy one there is a larger world beyond
the halls
of hogwarts so you can see the little
video playing here it's just the
hippogriff scene which i do think is
gameplay
now i think it's pretty safe to say the
majority of this game will take place at
hogwarts but this right here confirms
there are going to be
more locations i know there's been a lot
of talk a lot of discussion about
what will the other locations be i think
most of us just want to make sure they
nail hogwarts just make sure
that you give us an amazing hogwarts and
then whatever else you want to do is
just
the cherry on top i do think for sure
we're going to see places like hogsmeade
village that one's
a given maybe azkaban there's a spot in
the trailer that looks like azkaban to
me some other folks have wondered about
gringotts maybe the ministry of magic
diagon alley i think
all of those are definite possibilities
september 25th so you can see here in
the early going they were
tweeting every couple of days here right
after the game was announced
this one says learn from the world's
most talented professors to tame the
most fantastic
beasts now if you're new here i actually
have a
really big theory about the whole
beast's angle
with hogwarts legacy i think it's gonna
be a huge part of the game
they have focused on it so much i'm not
gonna rehash all that here but
there's there's a ton of details and
little nods
to the fact that fantastic beasts are
going to play a major
important role in this game and probably
even with the story it's not just going
to be some side thing in my opinion so
learn from the world's most talented
professors that seems like we're
definitely going to be taking classes
and then we have at least one confirmed
thing we'll be learning in those classes
and that is this
idea of taming fantastic beasts
september 30th not too much with this
one here your journey through hogwarts
is yours and yours alone maybe that's
hinting at yes this is only a
single-player adventure
instead though i think it's just really
speaking to the fact that they want this
to feel like a game where
you are making the choices that kind of
shape this world
and determine the legacy you leave on
hogwarts
october 5th is when we have to jump to
the next tweet and this one says
a wand chooses the witch or wizard
now sure there's a lot of stuff you
could read into this one here ultimately
i just think it's a nod to the books and
to the to the movie when mr ollivander
of course says
i wondered when i'd be seeing you
mr potter it seems only
yesterday that your mother and father
are in here buying their first
ones a one chooses the wizard mr potter
it's not always clear why mr ollivander
one of my favorite impressions to do
so is this enough to confirm diagon
alley i think so i think we're
definitely going to be going there at
some point to get a wand
whether it's in a flashback sequence
maybe it's the tutorial at the beginning
of the game
i think one thing a lot of people want
to know is how exactly will we get
the wands similar to the sorting are
they going to have some sort of quiz
here
or as the tweet says here a one chooses
the wizard i actually think we will get
to answer some questions on this one i
could see it being sort of dialogue that
you're having with
the wand maker here as he asks you some
things about your life and then you
respond with one of a couple of choices
that they give you
all right moving on here we have a big
jump we go from october 5th to november
17th so
over a month with just no information
and the november 17th troll troll in the
dungeon
not really sure there's too much to read
into this one here other than hey trolls
are confirmed
going back to that whole magical
creature bit again guys i'm telling you
they're going to be super important to
the game but after november 17th watch
what happens here we're going to jump to
november 19th so okay the updates
they're starting to be more frequent
again
here spread your wings with the
hippogriff a lot of this stuff is just
repeating what we already know from the
trailer but
hey hippogriffs confirmed also think
it's confirmed we're going to be able to
fly those hippogriffs as well
and then the most recent tweet coming
here on november 24th
know your foes from your friends now i'm
actually recording this video on
december 1st so
if you've seen anything after december
1st then it will not be covered in this
video maybe we'll have to do another one
later on
this one's fun because it could be
hinting at maybe there are going to be
some twists
and turns in the story of the game maybe
there are some characters that we assume
are on our side or some characters that
we assume are not on our side
and they turn out to flip allegiances
perhaps throughout the game i think this
would be great and a nice nod to the
original series because
harry potter was known for doing stuff
like this i mean i can remember as a kid
flipping to that page and seeing
it was quirrell and you're just like
what it's not snape i can't believe it
so i do think the fact that we're
starting to see
more frequent updates out of the social
media is telling us that they're
building to something
i think the next logical place would be
the game awards which take place on
december 10th it's a completely
different
type of game awards this year obviously
there won't be anyone there in person
jeff keeley's been doing a great job
with this award show the past couple of
years but this one will be
all online instead now jeff has promised
there's going to be new trailers world
premieres announcements all that sort of
stuff
is still going to be here so this really
does make sense if they want to have a
big
audience to put out some news to then
this is certainly a great opportunity to
do it the last time again was back in
september
we haven't really heard anything major
since that mid-september you see the
tweets we just went over all the tweets
it's definitely been more of a slow
trickle of information rather than
anything major announced
now one thing i would say is if the game
awards come and go and there's no big
announcement there's no new trailer
don't get too
discouraged because in this day and age
guys it is honestly super
easy for games to just drop a trailer
randomly when you don't even see it
coming and while the game awards is
certainly a good opportunity for big
games to get their news out there it's
also a great opportunity for smaller
games hogwarts legacy is
already a super well known game so these
guys could do an announcement anytime
they want and it would definitely be
covered by most of the major outlets
now because we're getting closer and
closer to the end of 2020 here this is
something else you have to think about
all we know so far about the release
date is 2021 they haven't said anything
about
early 2021 late 2021 summer so if it's
gonna be within those first three four
months then we should
really expect a big ramp up of new soon
and hopefully even a release date now if
we do get news at the game awards and it
does not
include a release date then i think
that's going to indicate the game is
further into 2021 maybe summer
or even late 2021. let me know when you
think we're gonna see news about
hogwarts legacy down in the comments
below
as always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon